thirty thousand girls and women living
in Germany have had genital mutilation
in high-rise development on the
outskirts of Dortmund I meet with 22
year old bintu she shares a small
apartment with her son a girlfriend has
come along with her daughter for support
then to tells me her story of being cut
at the age of 12 when she was growing up
in Gambia de toros but in one week time
you girls will be going for FTM but
you're going to kill your crocodile and
imagine a teenage girl going to kill see
a coracoid I face the crocodile and kill
that was so amazing and imagine if they
tell you that you're going to a place
where the money will be flowing from the
tree you can have any amount of money
you need you will be eating apples
bananas and lots of amazing things so it
was only joy that came to our house and
we couldn't even wait for the day to
come the women of the family brought Ben
two and thirty other girls to a distant
village that was only open to women
there was a big celebration and her
grandmother danced for them but during
the dance Ben - noticed her grandmother
was crying as he was singing in my local
language like if I can translate the
song in English is like the parts that
are flying inside the air you can tell
this my daughter does today her
shall I go with him we were attacked
Eagles that went but we came out last
less than thirty three girls were yet
according to our tradition they told us
that those skills we are eating by the
crocodile
they were blindfolded and their hands
were tied
then they led them one by one to an
exerciser a woman whose job it is to
perform FGM they've got my clitoris then
after 14 that the unit were mated
tomaten pasta
they used it Oh Martin first to cover it
these thematic ways have to mix with the
blood so that is how they call the
ceiling of the virginity been to blood
for days afterward when she spoke out
against the tradition her community
disowned her and left her on the fringe
okay I can continue her father hoped to
bring her back into the community by
forcing her to marry on the wedding
night the exes are arrived for a second
time they are opening for you to sleep
with your mom this razor blade like this
they will cut it into two only this age
they will use to force it inside you
they have to fast this thing inside the
vagina when the blood come out the man
have to jump on top of you the man have
to sleep with you by force because if
not it will if it is as well together
Oh again bent you defended yourself ran
away on her wedding night and in
response
her father threatened to kill her her
school helped her escape she made the
journey to Germany and was granted
asylum now she's making a new life here
and working as an apprentice to a cook
my body is lacking something very
important yeah
something really important the most
important part of my body has been
removed and that is something that can
never be brought up alive dia it's like
killing somebody and the person can
never be brought alive here because a
dead person is always a dead body
venture says she's often thought of
suicide but she's the sole caregiver for
her son and she wants him to have a
better life than her own she's telling
her story because she feels this is her
only weapon in the fight against FGM